quanto m'apporte tente de prendre la
parole dans l'hémicycle cet après-midi
bronca de la majorité présidentielle
lui en rajoute calmez-vous au collègue
il y a pas de ballons ici et la
polémique rebondit autour de cette photo
le député insoumis pose avec son écharpe
tricolore telle un footballeur le pied
sur un ballon à l'effigie d'Olivier du
soft nous exigeons des excuses de votre
part pour les probants que vous avez eu
l'attitude provocatrice qui est la vôtre
pour débattre on discutera voilà alors
on y est pendant ce temps-là
je retourne
rester avec nous oubliez les débats sur
le fond de la réforme la séance est
suspendue le député finalement
sanctionné Thomas porte est exclu 15
jours de l'Assemblée nationale il est
également privé de la moitié de son
indemnité parlementaire pendant 2 mois
cibler par cette photo celui qui porte
cette réforme des retraites au nom du
gouvernement Olivier du soft qui dès ce
matin s'adressant à un autre député
insoumis à répliquer vous voulez quoi
vous voulez recommencer vous voulez ma
tête comme vos collègues
[Musique]
cassez-vous
la vache vous voulez continuer dans la
violence mais vous voulez continuer dans
la stigmatisation vous aussi vous voulez
poser avec ma tête coupée derrière tout
cela une ambiance exécrable des députés
qui depuis quatre jours maintenant sans
victime
vous faites pitié vous faites pitié il
s'exaspère mais franchement voilà
maintenant 4 jours que nous sommes là
quatre jours et on n'avance pas une
demi-heure de perdues pour la bande qui
jure n'avoir rien à se reprocher
juste persécutation finalement cette
triangle
bourreau victime Sauveur le but est
d'alimenter les beaux aspects de
caractère
on peut pas sortir du triangle alors on
peut en sortir c'est à dire qu'on peut
inverser un peu la position si le
Sauveur devient un protecteur ça devient
intéressant c'est la victime devient
celui qui s'accepte ça devient
intéressant et si le bourreau devient
celui sur lequel on peut s'appuyer ça
devient intéressant mais quelle
philosophe c'est Kevin et j'adore tous
les le Chypre peut contiennent ces pays
aurait dû dire
nous avons la belle vie pas du tout vous
dès le 13000 amendement oh mon dieu
pouvoir un ballon mon dieu quelle
horreur qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ciel la
mort de ma femme dans le placard
quelle fatigue hier Jean-Luc Mélenchon
était sur plateau de BFM TV il s'était
énervé
j'ai le plateau attention vous pouvez le
faire
l'émission va être courte et il s'est
énervé il a quitté le plateau après une
question posée sur Adrien catenas et sa
présence à l'assemblée nationale qu'en
pensez-vous moi je suis pas là pour
commenter des petits codes RAM entre les
politiques et les médias vous pouvez
penser ce que vous voulez du tweet vous
pouvez en dire ce que vous voulez vous
pouvez le condamner etc le collègue dit
que c'est nul votre toutes les opinions
sont légitimes et acceptables ce que
vous pouvez pas faire c'est empêcher le
fonctionnement d'assemblée nationale
avant de fuir je voudrais juste vous
passer un dernier message
devant leur télé en train de se demander
mais pourquoi c'est comme ça ça ça ça
et pourquoi c'est comme ça ça ça ça et
pourquoi c'est comme ça le 7 mars ce
jour-là l'Inter syndicale appelle à
mettre la France à l'arrêt avec une
grève massive dans les transports
l'éducation nationale les centrales
nucléaires et les raffineries mais aussi
et c'est nouveau avec une baisse de
rideau de la part des commerçants même
une heure ou deux mais une interrogation
reste en suspens que vont faire les
syndicats les jours suivants la CGT RATP
a déjà annoncé une grève reconductible
les représentants de la SNCF se
concertent l'Inter syndicale pourrait
connaître sa première dissension si nous
avons l'obligation le devoir d'être
toujours au plus haut niveau nos
salaires sont loin de refléter ce live
d'en tenir compte stagnant depuis des
décennies nos fans sont difficiles même
lorsqu'on travaille régulièrement
pour ne rien arranger nous sommes
frappés par l'annulation de nombreux
spectacles les créations du fait de la
baisse des financements alloués à la
culture face à la perspective d'un
blocage le gouvernement inflexible sur
le report de l'âge légal à 64 ans se dit
prêt à faire d'autres concessions est-ce
qu'il y a encore des gestes possibles
oui ah oui bien sûr on est à l'écoute ce
qu'on veut si vous voulez c'est d'abord
qu'on puisse que les parlementaires
puissent avoir l'occasion de faire leur
travail un flot continue de gland Nick
est intervenu dans une maison en
Californie dont les occupants se
plaignaient de la présence d'asticots en
faisant un trou dans le mur il
s’éviteront du compte du problème 300 kg
de glandes étaient stockés là par des
oiseaux comme ceci des piques gland
divorcs qui portent bien leur nom comme
dans tant d'autres précaires avec des
salaires irréguliers nous ne sommes pas
rassurés par le projet de réforme des
retraites dont les modalités de calcul
nous serons encore plus défavorable que
aujourd'hui
61 % des Français ont hâte d'être à la
retraite donc sondage audoxa de novembre
dernier et le simple fait de nommer les
choses fait bouger les lignes selon vous
tout comme Zola qui pensaient que si on
décrit une réalité infâme cette réalité
commence à changer du simple fait d'en
avoir parlé car on l'a tiré de
l'obscurité et d'une certaine manière la
lumière apporte déjà le changement c'est
ce que vous vous écrivez dans le livre
mais il faut être prêt du coup être
ostracisé à être montré du doigt quand
j'entends dire que c'était mieux avant
je réponds que ce sera encore mieux
après
[Musique]
et entre les deux
entre les deux il y a le présent il y a
aujourd'hui non seulement on sera bossu
donc on aura un coup et des épaules
courbés mon aura aussi des coudes à
angles droits des mains en forme de avec
des griffes et une deuxième paupière
pour se protéger des écrans dans 1000
ans